what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
we have a lot of news today but one of
the most important pieces of news
information that has come out today is
about Tina cuerta if you haven't heard
he was recently accused of sexual
assault this allegation was made against
him by the musician Maria Elena Rios now
many people are already thinking oh
great this is another Jonathan Majors
case here Jonathan Majors who plays King
the Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe was recently arrested and is
currently in court for some assault
charges he has not been proved innocent
and he has not been proved guilty
everyone is waiting what the court is
going to decide and everybody is waiting
to see what Marvel Studios is going to
decide to do with Jonathan majors are
they going to recast him are they going
to Simply move away from the character
there are a lot of decisions that Marvel
needs to make right now which has fans
on the edge of their seats and now we
have the sexual assault allegations
coming out against another actor who
plays another villain of the MCU you
however this one seems a little bit more
straightforward and today tenakuerta
himself has even come out and talked a
lot about the situation calling it
completely false so right off the bat it
doesn't seem like we have to worry too
much at the possibility of Marvel
Studios possibly recasting the more the
Submariner who of course was the villain
of black panther wakanda forever and not
only that but no more or Namor the
Submariner in the comics is a major
Marvel villain he's a really big deal in
the comics he is a major part of the
Avengers vs X-Men story and not to
mention he is one of the original
members of The Illuminati now Namor does
ride that line of hero or villain in the
comics he's always kind of right in
between and you never really know what
he's gonna do and that's how we kind of
see him in the MCU right now he was the
villain of wakanda forever but perhaps
he could turn good but once he turns
good he could definitely switch back
again and go against wakanda and the
rest of the world we already know that
that's what he wants to do so he plays a
big role in the comic accent is going to
be playing a big role in the MCU so it
is good news that he has come out and
addressed all of this himself most
likely due to what he's seen happen with
Jonathan Majors but it really does seem
like he is not at much Jeopardy right
now of losing the role or being recast
let's dive into what he said now as I
mentioned about the claims it's pretty
straightforward Maria Elena Rios has
accused the Marvel actor of sexually
assaulting her and she called him a
sexual predator however as it turns out
Maria isn't just some woman who happens
to know tinakuerto or has been around
him a few times as it turns out they
actually dated and we find this out from
tinakuerta himself and today in a pretty
long statement addressing these
allegations here's what he had to say
this statement was sent directly to
variety and published on his Instagram
and he says that these claims are false
and completely
unsubstantiated and he said I cannot let
it go unchallenged any longer about a
year ago I dated Elena for several
months it was was entirely consensual at
all times as countless others can attest
and throughout it was a loving warm and
mutually supportive relationship after
it ended however Elena began to
misrepresent our interactions both
privately and in front of groups of
mutual friends so there's more to his
statement but right off the bat he
basically states that a lot of people
can attest that they were dating in a
very consensual relationship and that he
was very loving and warm then they broke
up and she essentially started to
misrepresent their relationship stating
that that's not how it actually was and
that he was actually sexually assaulting
her and apparently this went on for a
little bit and then tenar cuerta said
this as a result a few months ago I
engaged a legal team to commence the
appropriate actions to protect my
reputation and refute these
irresponsible and false accusations that
can cause great prejudice and damage
although I am by no means perfect I know
that these allegations are simply untrue
and while I will always work to him
improve myself I need to contest claims
that are both false and defensive now as
always with this type of news that comes
out we try to remain pretty neutral
however since tinakuerta took legal
action three months ago way before these
claims even came out to the public and
the fact that they did actually date and
there are a lot of witnesses that can
say that Tina cuerta was indeed a loving
person to Maria it seems like Tena
cuerta isn't in a terrible spot right
now not like Jonathan Majors with the
case of Jonathan Majors when these
allegations came out when he got
arrested a lot of people came out online
and started to stay yeah we've had
really bad experiences with him as well
he's not a nice person he's hard to work
with etc etc even though Jonathan Majors
seemingly has a lot of evidence proven
that he is innocent these people coming
out with these statements definitely did
not help a situation and it puts a lot
of pressure on Marvel Studios at that
point in time but with Tina cuerta it
seems very different he has already been
trying to get the situation and his name
clear it up privately he hired a legal
team and they were handling the
situation trying to make sure that these
claims weren't viewed as true when he
says that they are undeniably false and
again he says that there are a lot of
people out there that can testify that
they were actually in a very loving
relationship before and then when it
broke up things kind of got nasty as a
lot of us know can happen now we don't
know exactly what is going on of course
both parties are saying something
different but what it looks like on the
outside as far as tinok's career in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is concerned
it still seems pretty solid this isn't
anything like the Jonathan Majors case
he wasn't arrested and he was already
trying to clear his name privately on
his own legally for months now so as far
as tenacuerto being in Jeopardy of being
recast as name or the Submariner I don't
think he's in that much Jeopardy right
now especially if he's already three
months into the legal process of trying
to get his name cleared before any of
this came to the surface so he is most
likely already been talking to Marvel
Studios and Disney about all of this and
a lot of people that have worked with
Tina cuerta on sets in the past have all
said that he was an absolute pleasure to
work with and nobody else right now is
coming out stating yeah Tina cuerta yeah
he is actually a bad person we have been
trying to tell people that for a long
time in fact it's the opposite
tenacuerto is saying go ahead ask
anybody they can attest that I was a
good boyfriend I had a great
relationship with Maria until of course
it ended and the fact that they dated
and had a good relationship also does
help his case now of course that doesn't
mean that nothing happened and again
until it's all made very clear we don't
really know but as far as tinaku where
to possibly being recast in the MCU that
doesn't seem very likely right now and
it does seem like he is going to be
coming back to the MCU maybe not soon
but definitely in Phase seven when the
mutants and the X-Men are going to be
coming to the MCU he was called a mutant
in Black Panther wakanda forever he
called himself a mutant actually then
after black panther what kind of Forever
Came Out Kevin feige when talking about
the future of the X-Men even said we
already have some mutants in the MCU did
you meet Namor in Black Panther wakanda
forever confirming he is indeed a mutant
and when the X-Men and the mutants
finally do come in Phase seven he should
play a big part because as I mentioned
in Marvel Comics Namor is a pretty big
character plus not to mention the
representation that he has for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe a lot of
people including myself because I am
part Mexican were really excited to see
him come into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I've heard many people talk
about how he was so cool and how they
were so excited to see their own
representation in the MCU even though he
was kind of a bad guy it was still
really cool to see and hopefully his
role as Namor or no more the Submariner
is not a Jeopardy we already have enough
to deal with right now with the Jonathan
Majors allegations we don't want to lose
another villain because it does seem
like Jonathan Majors is in great
Jeopardy right now hopefully Tina cuerta
isn't it doesn't seem like he is but of
course as always if we hear anything
else about the situation if anything new
develops we'll be sure to do an update
so don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos and also
if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're entered in our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month also don't forget to follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
foreign